what was some of the most shocking stuff
that like popped up because i mean
every guy that i've talked to that's
gone through the divorce machine is
always like well
i never saw that one coming and it's not
always the same thing for every guy i'm
just wondering what yours was
oh there were there was there were
several i think the first one was
certainly the infidelity but that
believe it or not that then bought that
it really didn't bother me i'm like
whatever but now it started to bother me
a little bit as i looked
back at um five years of medical claims
and and discovered that
she pretty much had every std out there
she had prescriptions for antibiotics 23
prescriptions
she was getting scripts for everything
that she could cure yeah 23
prescriptions for antibiotics in a 45
month period
so one every two months oh smokes
and again i'm in the pharmaceutical
industry and many of these medications i
had to look up and go
what's this what's it oh this is for
vaginal burning and itching oh my god
she had
12 prescriptions for yeast infections
and i'm like so
that that was became laughable to me i
think
the the thing that shocked me the most
that i discovered first
was her there were two prescriptions in
her pharmacy claims
again going back five years so i had
massive amounts of pharmacy claims to
look at
that i discovered those the day after
she dropped the grenade on me about the
herpes thing because i'm like well [ __ ]
i should look at her pharmacy claims if
she's got herpes she's got to be on
something
and i found i found two pharmacy claims
every month
going back five years that were marked
private
the rest of them it would tell you what
what the medication was it never tells
you to claim who wrote it
but i worked with our insurance company
and finally got to the right person and
said look i'm paying all the medical
bills
i'm the primary card holder i want to
know what these prescriptions are and i
want to know who's writing them
that shocked me when i discovered the
adderall and the outer lxr
because we spent i don't know how much
money
going to cardiologists because she was
having
significant cardiac issues
she had two or two or three stroke-like
and i used stroke like in parentheses
because it wasn't ultimately wasn't a
stroke but she had what they called a
cerebral vascular event
she had two of them during our marriage
but yet never told anybody
that oh by the way i'm on two different
strengths of amphetamines
so that was a result of the meds that
she was on some some of which was to
deal with her anxiety and some of which
was to deal with the stds she kept
getting
yeah yeah after five years she was
obviously cheating on you for a few
years then
oh absolutely yeah absolutely and i it
might have been throughout our entire
marriage i don't know
did you just rub your hands just say
[ __ ] it i'm out
i should i should have done that after i
got out of the psychiatric facility but
again i say i'm glad that i didn't
because i mean a good lord wanted me to
hang on for something but i'm glad that
i didn't because
the third gift may never have been
revealed the herpes may never been
revealed i believe she contract
she contracted well my std expert
who wrote the cdc guidelines for
treating stds we found this guy
uh i won't tell you where we found him
but he was close enough to where i where
i live
uh side sidebar on this a little bit
because
it's not in the book to protect his
protect his identity a little bit but
when i meet with him
to go over the results and to talk about
things um
he's like yeah my now ex-wife did this
to me too i said what do you mean
he said she was accusing me of having
affairs when she was screwing a guy in
chicago and
screwing a guy in cincinnati ohio and uh
and he says ah she's crazy and i said
are you saying that diagnostically or
are you just being flippant he said no
she's got borderline personality
disorder and i'm like oh my god that's
what they think my now ex-wife has yeah
well i mean you read it my chapter when
you've got vpd
you tend to act out in such a way to
ensure abandonment's going to happen
right
so yeah
you